As American as apple pie,...
...the old-fashioned hamburger is going through some design changes...
...thanks in part to the worst recession since the 1930s.
Greg Cook is head chef at the BLT Mirage in Las Vegas.
I think with the economy the way it is now,...
...honestly, I think there is more room for profit in a burger restaurant...
...than there is in a steak house right now.
I think that the general public, I think you can always afford to have a burger.
And restaurants have been quick to capitalize.
At the Munch Bar at Caesars Palace,...
...owner Bryan Ogden says his cooks have turned a fast-food sandwich into a fine dining experience.
We're using certified Black Angus beef.
It's all organic, no hormones.
We go in the farmers' markets every day, picking out the ingredients,...
...the lettuces, you know, washing them ourselves...
...and doing all the organic romaines and icebergs,...
...and different boutique lettuces like red leaf,...
...making our own jalapeno mayonnaise, spicy remoulades,...
...little relishes, homemade relishes from scratch.
It takes a lot of stuff that goes into this every day...
...and our guys start early in the morning prepping the ingredients fresh daily.